[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: So I'm Joanna.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I'm Alicia.
JOANNA SMITH: I guess you might
have figured that part out,
but we are developer advocates
for G Suite, which, yes,
is a product with a platform.
Who knew that?
That's what I thought.
That's OK, though.
Because we're going
to make you so excited
that you're all
going to be like,
I'm done listening to them.
I'm just going to
open my computer
and do some G Suite
magic right now.
Right?
So you're ready?
You're ready?
OK, so we want to
talk about auto
magic and quarterly
reports because we all
hate doing the things
that our managers ask
us to do that keep us from
writing our code, right?
Man, it's tedious.
It's not hard.
It's just really
annoying sometimes.
Because let's think about it.
The last time that you had to
do some sort of summary, monthly
or quarterly, you probably
went to your inbox order drive
and was like, where was
the last quarter's report?
And then you opened it up,
made a copy, changed the title,
changed a couple of slides,
took that to your meeting,
and then everyone called
you out when you kind of
forgot to update slide 7.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Somebody had to do it.
JOANNA SMITH: I really
appreciate your attention
to detail.
You're a great teammate.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
It's my 20% project.
JOANNA SMITH: Cool.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
So it's approved.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, that was
really nice how you did that.
So now I'm never going to
copy anything ever again,
but I still don't want to do the
work because every time I think
about it, I'm like, oh my
gosh, a chart, and a table,
and numbers, they're so hard.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Chart
title, that was a hard one.
JOANNA SMITH: It was just
tedious and annoying,
and I don't want to do it.
OK, so how can we
get around this?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I
think there's a way.
JOANNA SMITH: No,
I'm like asking you.
I forgot what I was going--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I
think there's a way.
Oh, I thought you
were going to tell me.
JOANNA SMITH:
Shiitake mushrooms.
OK, so-- oh, yeah,
I remember now.
There's two problems
we have to solve.
One, we need fresh data because
the last quarter's data is just
going to get us
in trouble, right?
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
I mean, sometimes
it's getting Joanna in trouble.
I'm usually perfect,
so it doesn't really
get me in trouble.
JOANNA SMITH: You and
Milton are just always so
mean to me in meetings.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
I love my teammates.
They're great.
But the things is after
you get your fresh data,
you really want a way to
do the tedious generating
of the report part for you.
And we're going to show
you how we wrote that.
And you can just
copy it if you want.
It's on GitHub.
So we start-- oh my god.
This is still running.
There's so many charts.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
I mean, these are weekly, too.
JOANNA SMITH: First problem--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Fresh data!
JOANNA SMITH: It's fresh data!
We need our data to be
the freshest, right?
And we all saw all the keynotes
and the developer keynote.
In 4.75 seconds, your postcard
photo can go around the world.
This is great.
So how can we use Google to
make sure that your data is
so fresh that nobody
ever calls you out again?
Just because of slide 7.
I'm over it.
I promise.
I'm totally over it.
I'm not upset at all.
OK, well, there's this thing
called the BigQuery data
connector.
You might have heard of this.
You probably also
in our keynote saw
the preview of our
Connected Sheets Initiative.
This is actually going to make
it a lot easier because you
don't have to spend any time.
You don't have to
spin up App Engine.
You can get access
to any of your data
on almost all data
set platforms that
are out there through
different connectors.
BigQuery was the first data
connector we ever built.
We announced it last year,
which means that this year,
you could use it.
Right?
And then we also have a
Salesforce data connector.
The whole connected Sheets
thing will be so cool
when we turn it on for you.
So the idea is that if
you're using G Suite already
for your company,
which I know you
all are because we're
the best product ever.
And please don't say
otherwise if you don't agree.
That will hurt my feelings.
But if you have an
enterprise or a business
G Suite account, and you're
running your business off
of it, now you can actually
make it really, really
easy for anyone in your
company who needs access
to data to actually grab it when
they need it without needing
to have any kind of knowledge
about what data even really is.
And it's all because
of a UI based connector
that we're really proud
of, but we didn't build it.
So don't be proud of us.
OK.
That was the whole
solution for problem one.
This is a product that exists
thanks to the engineering team.
And we didn't do
anything for it.
So you should all use it because
it's really, really cool.
So the hard problem is
all that tedious work
that I really don't want to do.
Do you want to do it?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah,
the copy and paste.
JOANNA SMITH: Do
you want to do it?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Copy and paste.
JOANNA SMITH: You should do it.
Do you ever have
those days where you--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I'll do it,
and then I'll just use this.
JOANNA SMITH: Go to
work, and you just
feel like you're
staring at your computer
and not doing anything at all?
But everyone's like, oh, man,
you're such a hard worker.
And you're like, yeah, I am.
Definitely didn't copy and
paste that from last time.
So we're going to
solve those days
so that when you are zoning
out, you can just play
all the Solitaire you want.
And no one will--
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Legit zoning out.
No copy and paste.
JOANNA SMITH: Best zoning out.
No errors to catch later on.
OK, so the way that
this actually works
is I've already mentioned,
we're going talk about Sheets.
And obviously, we're going to
use Slides for our presentation
because G Suite is the best
ever and has all the things
that you need.
And you never have
to go anywhere else
outside of your browser.
But the thing that makes
it all come together
is what we call Apps Script.
This is our magic component.
One person knows what this is.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
You're like the third
I've met all week.
Has anyone here ever actually
opened this script editor
for Apps Script?
Oh my gosh, that's just
doubled my number for the week.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOANNA SMITH: No,
this is really great.
OK, so this has been
around for a decade,
and now that you all
know that it exists,
you're going to be really,
really excited about it
because it's the
easiest thing ever.
And more importantly
than that, it's
the most magical thing
that ever existed.
It's basically a unicorn
rocket sailing into the sun
without burning up and is pink.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: Isn't that
what your dreams look like?
What does your dream look like?
Are you sure?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: It will now.
JOANNA SMITH: Are you dreaming?
Because a unicorn rocket
that's bright pink,
sailing into the sun
without burning up
is basically the
coolest thing ever.
Just like Apps Script, right?
OK, so a brief context
on Apps Script,
which is why you're
all going to love it,
because the thing I
love about Apps Script
is that it's written inside
of your drive editor.
It compiles in Drive.
It runs from Drive.
We can deploy it from Drive.
It has triggers from Drive.
So basically if
you're a [INAUDIBLE],,
you could do it
in like 30 minutes
and solve a problem that you
really hate having to do.
But if you're not
[INAUDIBLE],, it's
actually incredibly
approachable,
and you can get a lot done with
very little coding experience.
So literally, all of
you should love this.
Do you love it?
OK, you will.
I'll come back to you.
OK, so right here,
we have an example.
We have five lines of code.
And then five lines
of code, we're
using three different
Google services
to basically pull an
address out of the map,
find the actual map
of that location,
and email it to a friend.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I'm
friend@example.com.
JOANNA SMITH: I'm going to mail
it to Milton because I'm still
a little sore with you.
Wait, have you
seen Milton lately?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I haven't,
and he's actually the one
that usually gets us the data.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, he's the
one we get all our data from.
If y'all see
Milton, let me know.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: We're
going to figure it out.
JOANNA SMITH: So five lines
of code, three services,
and it actually
really is this simple.
There's no setup.
There's no libraries to thing.
There's no plugins to install.
Oh my gosh, you never
have to go back to Maven
again if you don't want to.
You could just join my Apps
Script club [INAUDIBLE]..
Wouldn't that be great?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah, it would.
Yeah, it would.
JOANNA SMITH: So it's
really, really simple.
Spreadsheet app, that gets
you to the spreadsheet,
and you can get
the current sheet.
You can get a sheet by an
ID or a sheet by a name.
You can search
through your Drive.
This is just the magic world.
And then we expand to other
Google services, such as Maps.
And these are called
our advanced services.
And if you'd like to know more,
go to developers.google.com.
OK, so now that you are all
in love with Apps Script
and how great and easy it is.
And you totally
believe me, and you
have no questions whatsoever.
Alicia is going to give a demo.
And this is the best
demo ever because it
was written by our
friend and co-worker Anu,
and she's the best.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Is she here?
JOANNA SMITH: So again,
don't be proud of us
because we didn't do this,
except Alicia made it better.
So she did a little bit of work.
But don't be proud of me.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: All right.
So this is a real example
of a presentation we gave
at Acme Corporation recently.
JOANNA SMITH: We
definitely went there,
and we definitely gave
this presentation.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: We're
finding that we're
having to make this presentation
for all of our customers.
But here's what it looks like.
We start out logo,
talk about the team.
Who's the sales team?
What opportunities do we have?
We have a pie chart
there, business revenue.
What are our top closes?
How many widgets have we sold?
How many widgets are
we about to sell?
How many widgets need attention?
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, we're so
professional and business-y.
We've got this down.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
This is slide 7.
I just thought I'd
point that out.
So we found out
that this is kind
of following the same template.
And actually, if any of
you have done mail merge,
you might see we kind of merged
this into a Slides template.
So we're using some
curly brackets here.
Just, it's kind of
whatever you want to use.
You could use maybe a
unicorn with a rocket.
JOANNA SMITH: But
those are our flair.
I think it's important
to have flair,
and we like curly brackets.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yes,
that's our flair.
So we kind of went
through this deck
and we took each of our fields
and added curly brackets.
And you can see here we have
a really nice template of what
that slide deck looks like.
So just like mail
merge, we're going
to be able to take our data
and just kind of merge it
into the slide deck.
You can already
imagine that, right?
But we talked about
getting the fresh data.
So I'm going to go
into my spreadsheet.
I'm going to show you this
is the data connector.
So this is connected out to our
BigQuery opportunities table.
And I'm actually pulling
in a specific query here.
I'll show you the query.
It's really simple.
This is about one
of my SQL right now.
JOANNA SMITH: This is what your
queries all look like, right?
They're all so simple.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: So I'm
select starring everything
from this table.
I've created a where class
for my account in my region
because I do these slide
decks for a specific company
in a specific region.
And I can just actually
tie those parameters
to a different tab or field
reference in my spreadsheet.
So I'll show you
where I have that.
I'm kind of setting
up this like, hey,
if Alicia didn't show
up next week, how
could we create the slide deck?
Well--
JOANNA SMITH: Because I
definitely can't be trusted.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: You just have
to click that account name
that you want, like our
unicorn rocket ship company
that we like to work with.
And I'm from the Midwest.
So I can go over here to
my table, click Refresh,
and it will take those
parameters in, go out
to the query, and
pull my data back in.
So now that I have my data,
I need to somehow get it
into my slide deck.
That's actually where
that Apps Script comes in.
So this is the Code Editor
that I can access directly
from my spreadsheet.
And I have some code here, and
this code does a couple things.
So the first thing it does is it
takes that template slide deck,
and it makes a copy.
And it just renames it for us.
And then down here, let's see.
We create our intro slide so
we take our CR curly brackets.
So we're going to
replace our account
name with the actual
account name, region
with the actual region.
See it gets a little bit
more interesting down here.
We're actually going to make
a chart, so [INAUDIBLE]..
So add actually a
temporary tab, where
we're going to make a chart.
And we're going
to copy and paste
that chart into our slide deck.
JOANNA SMITH: And
then we're going
to clean up our
work because that's
what good programmers do.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
And then down here,
to get kind of our top
closes, near closes,
we actually just do a
little bit of sorting
on those values
in the spreadsheet
and then replace that
text in the slide.
So now that I have my
code ready to kind of take
all of that data
and merge it in,
I have a little
button over here that
just kicks off that slide deck.
So I'll hit Generate.
This button is tied to my Apps
Script so anyone in the sheet
can create their own report.
So while it's
running, it's going
to start running my script.
And at some point,
we're going to see
this really cool tab come up.
It's like a dance party time.
Like woo, slide deck.
This is going to be copied
and pasted and then completely
destroyed, but don't worry.
It's in the slide deck.
And then we can see in
our Drive that it has just
created this new slide deck.
JOANNA SMITH: And I bet slide
7 is accurate this time.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
I mean, we'll see.
JOANNA SMITH: Just make one
mistake at Google [INAUDIBLE]
ALICIA WILLIAMS: And it's
looking pretty accurate.
Yeah.
We'll have to talk to
Diane about that actually.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, yeah.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: So I
think that's about it.
Now I think I've
just taken something
that probably takes me--
I don't know-- like an
hour to eight hours a day.
JOANNA SMITH: Depending on
how much you're focusing.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Depending on how much
you're staring at your computer.
And so I think I'm
going to just head
on down to Chotchkie's now.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, but--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I don't
even have to stay at work.
JOANNA SMITH: Wait,
before you go,
could you maybe show them how
you got to some of this stuff?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Oh, yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So let's go
back to the spreadsheet.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I can show you.
JOANNA SMITH: How do you
open the BigQuery data--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOANNA SMITH: How
would you get started?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: If you want
to get started with that,
you can just go to the
data menu, Data Connectors,
and BigQuery.
And then it brings up a new--
you select your billing project,
and it'll create a new tab.
So you can have multiple
tabs within one spreadsheet
that pull from different
tables, if you like.
JOANNA SMITH: Different
ways, different queries.
And that is it.
That's the whole fresh
data problem solved.
So I feel like that's some
props for our engineering teams
that aren't here.
We didn't invite them
because that's not their job.
This is our job.
But we're very proud of them.
So everyone be really happy
for our engineering teams.
Thanks, y'all.
Thank you.
I'll be sure to tell them
that you clapped for them.
Wait, can you go back
to the demo actually?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Oh, yeah.
Do you see more?
JOANNA SMITH: I want to see--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: How do
I get to Apps Script?
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, let's
go back to the Apps Script.
Yeah.
How would you open it?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: So just
from the Tools menu,
you can go to Scripts Editor.
And that will open
up this tab here.
JOANNA SMITH: And now
there's a really cool thing
about Apps Script, which is
from any Google document,
whether it's actually a
doc, or a sheet, or a slide,
you can always open from
inside the document,
and that Apps Script will
be bound to that document.
So if you share that
with somebody else,
they can actually edit the
script if they need to.
And they can run it.
It makes it really easy.
But if you ever wanted
to make a script that's
separate from any existing
document, how would
you do that?
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Script.google.com.
JOANNA SMITH: Script.google.com.
It's really easy.
I hope you can remember it.
But if you can't, once again,
it's script.google.com.
Should we say it
four more times?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: You
should just tweet at us,
and then we can tweet back--
JOANNA SMITH: I should tweet it.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Script.google.com.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah,
we could tell you
if you ask us on Twitter.
But also, at script.google.com,
you can see all of your scripts
that you have written and--
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
All the executions.
JOANNA SMITH: Information
on their executions
and whether or not they're still
going on every night at 2:00
in the morning to update your
calendar for you because you're
really bad at that.
And then one other thing I
want to talk about-- can we
go back to the spreadsheet?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: And to
the tab that you wrote,
the generator tab.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Oh, yeah.
This is my fave.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So I'm going to guess that not
everyone you work with at work
is as clever as you all are.
Right?
That's a thing.
It's very frustrating sometimes.
But you don't have to waste any
more time explaining to them
how your code works.
You can just be like,
trust me, it works.
I tested it.
There's definitely a unit test.
It's definitely
never going to fail.
And instead, you can make
an interactive way for them
to use an Apps
Script so that you
don't have to keep sending
the same email every month.
And it saves your day.
It saves your time.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
And they don't even
have to go into the editor.
So this is something
that I could do.
It makes it really easy
for me to make the report,
but it's really great
when I go out of town,
or I want to transition
that report to somebody
else once you get slides--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOANNA SMITH: We'll
give it to Milton.
I shouldn't be trusted.
But Alicia actually made this
because of her experience
having to live her entire
life in spreadsheets
and knowing how
incredibly tedious
it can be to even remember
what you yourself did,
never mind what
somebody else did.
And this is one of
my favorite plugs
for Apps Script, which is
make it easy for everyone else
that you interact with, and
it'll still be easy for you.
All right, so--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: All right.
JOANNA SMITH: That's
a pretty cool demo.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Let's go back.
Oh, I guess our demo's over.
Bye, magic people.
So a couple of gotchas.
Once again, BigQuery
data connectors
are for business and
enterprise G Suite accounts.
If you have a Gmail account,
you might not actually
want to try this.
Maybe just don't do that,
because otherwise, you'll
be sad.
But I don't want you to be sad.
I want you to be happy
people with your business
and enterprise G Suite accounts.
The other thing is that
data access is important.
In order to use an
Apps Script, in order
to use the BigQuery
data connector,
you do need to have access
to that original document
or to that data set.
And if you don't, this
can make it kind of tricky
to run our specific demo that's
definitely available online.
And we even have a link to prove
that one so you can trust me
on this phrase.
Because sometimes I'm a liar.
But if you don't have access,
it's not the end of the world
because Apps Script
is super duper magic.
Oh, we should have copied our
unicorn over to the next slide,
so I could emphasize how
awesome a super cool unicorn
rocket that flies into
the sun without burning up
and is bright pink is.
Do you believe me now?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Apps
Script works on any account.
JOANNA SMITH: It
works on any account.
It doesn't have
to be in G Suite.
It can be a Gmail account.
You can make them for yourself.
You can make them
for your company.
You can do a domain
wide installation.
You can sell them as an
add on in the marketplace.
They are full magic, and full
awesome, and very, very easy
to make.
We have one on our
team that everyone
has stolen that our TL made
that literally just crops
a spreadsheet to the
cells that you're using.
So you don't have
1,000 rows by accident.
Love that thing.
But the other thing
is Apps Script
can still solve problems.
Maybe you don't have
access to the data
set that you need to include in
your analysis for some reason.
It's some other team,
but it's relevant
to your entire initiative.
But if you get a monthly
update email from them,
you could write an Apps
Script to look for that email,
copy the information
over, and then include it
in your work
automatically without ever
having to read the email because
it could still be filtered.
We all love our filters.
And if you don't know
how your filters work,
you should talk to me in about
three minutes and 11, 10, 9
seconds.
So it basically never ends.
And then there's a lot more
things that actually can help.
Like, if you haven't started
with Apps Script yet,
and you're terrified
of JavaScript that
dates back to the 1990s or
something like that, that's OK,
too.
Because last year, we
released the macro recorder
for Google Sheets.
And what the macro
recorder does is
it records every click that
you make inside of your sheet
so that you can color
everything once, make a new tab,
and then run it
again and not have
to go through all
of those 78 clicks
every single time
you have a new tab.
And this is a great thing.
But what's really cool is
you can edit the macros that
were made for you.
And if you do that,
you'll actually
get a fully written Apps Script,
a very tedious robotically
written code.
But it can show you
how things work.
So if you're having some
trouble with A1 notation,
record what you're trying to
do as a macro, look at it,
and then steal
from the computer.
Yeah.
This is how engineering
works, and everyone's always
intimidated.
You're like, yeah, all we
do is go to Stack Overflow
and then steal things
that are already written.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: You
can even macro record
refreshing the data
from the data connector.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, yeah.
We did that last night, but
we forgot to include it.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I
don't want to do it here
because I like the dramatic
effect of refreshing the data.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah,
the button press.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: And to
feel like you did something.
Otherwise, you really
didn't do anything.
JOANNA SMITH: And
also, we wanted
to make sure it was
accurate last night,
and then we didn't really
want to do anything
this morning because we were
tired and stayed up till 3:00.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: OK,
honesty came out.
JOANNA SMITH: I really
want to go home already.
But I'm having so much fun with
y'all so I'm not going to go
home early.
So now to check in, are you
in love with Apps Script?
Is there anything about it that
you're like, nah, a hard pass?
That's what I thought.
See that?
No hard passes.
The whole world loves it.
You're all convinced--
ALICIA WILLIAMS: We've
converted everyone in the room.
JOANNA SMITH: That
this is the greatest
thing that ever existed.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: I'm excited.
JOANNA SMITH: And that
is how you can auto
magic your quarterly reports
and never have to do them again
while your boss still thinks
you're working really, really
hard.
Maybe don't show him
this YouTube video.
But show your friends
because my personality
makes a lot more
sense on YouTube
than it does in real life.
If you have any
questions, tweet us.
We actually answer with some
fairly quick response times.
But we will answer eventually.
And then check out the blog
post that Alicia and Anu wrote.
Copy their code.
Steal it.
Use it for your own purposes.
We don't care.
And then go to our
developers.google.com page
because our tech writers
are the best tech
writers in the whole world.
And they're ours,
and they're the best,
and they work really hard.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: Anything else?
ALICIA WILLIAMS: That's how I
got started with Apps Script.
JOANNA SMITH: That is how you
got started, like a year ago.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So we're
going to go to Chotchkie's.
Y'all stay here.
Have fun.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Start writing.
JOANNA SMITH: And bye.
ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]